Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich glaube, letztes Mal haben wir uns so verausgabt. Heute wird das nicht so umfangreich, oder?
Ja, vor allem nicht die Cocktails danach.
Cocktails? Wo gab's denn Cocktails?
Soll ich da jetzt Werbung machen für Cocktails? Die waren aber.
Meine wer wer also ich hab keine gekriegt. Ach so stimmt.
Nee, du wolltest ja nicht mehr mit. Du du bist ja schon nach Schnitzel und Bier gegangen.
Ja, ich hatte noch nicht mal Schnitzel.
Auch nicht, ich bin ja Vegetarier.
War auf jeden Fall eine recht äh epische Ausgabe letztes Mal und äh gleich danach ist die Nachrichtenlage dann doch deutlich ausgedünnt.
Zum Glück.
Ja, immerhin nicht so viele negativ Schlafzeilen.
Weiß der Geier. Jetzt müssen sie sich die Ausschüsse erstmal wieder neue Bösartigkeiten ausdenken, über die wir dann berichten können. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass nichts äh zu berichten wäre. Ähm,
Ja, womit fangen wir denn mal an? Also zumindest äh eine eine Bösigkeit äh steht im Raum.
Und zwar schreit, das IFF und ähm mit dem IFF,
die äh Gruppe, wie heißt sie noch gleich so schön, ähm Defective by Design,
die sich ja schon vor längerer Zeit äh gegründet hat,
und äh verweisen auf einen ja, einen Entwurf für einen W3C-Standard zur Erweiterung von äh HTML oder HTML fünf,
um genauer zu sein,
Um diese Media-Elemente, Audio- und Video, um äh ein Abi zu erweitern, was den Austausch von Verschlüsselungskies,
erlauben würde, beziehungsweise definieren würde, wie ein solcher Austausch konform zu erfolgen hat,
Und äh damit es natürlich auch absehbar, wofür das gedacht ist, äh nämlich
zur Implementierung von DRM, Datenströmen, also verschlüsselten Audio oder Videocontent, der dann erst beim User, also im Browser entschlüsselt wird.
Ja, um dann vielleicht noch kurz das nochmal genauer zu erklären. Der Punkt ist nicht, dass die,
Verschlüsselt stattfindet, zum Schutze des Users. Das wäre ja mit einer mit einer SSL-Verbindung ähm sehr,
schön lösbar, sondern es findet eine Verschlüsselung statt, statt zum Schutz vor dem User,
Ähm also der Inhalt dieses dieses man hat quasi man hat seine Verbindung aufgebaut und dann steht in dem HTML steht dann, guck mal hier kommt jetzt ein Video.
Und dieses Video ist ähm übrigens mit einem Schlüssel versehen und diesen Schlüssel und und die Entschlüsselung,
regelst du von mir aus mit dieser oder jener Funktion oder diesem und je im Plugin und äh weiß schon Bescheid. Ähm,
Warum sie das jetzt in dem HTML selber drin haben wollen
ist, damit sie, also sie könnten ja auch sagen, man braucht einfach von mir aus einen Player dafür oder so. Aber warum sie das in einem RTL drin haben wollen, ist damit ein normaler Browser dann auch den entsprechenden Federkode auswirft und sagt,
ja dieser Inhalt ist mit Rechten versehen oder oder zum Ansehen dieses Inhalts benötige ich Rechte und die habe ich nicht.
Es geht nicht nur um die Fehler mehr, es geht natürlich generell dadrum, auch die Applikationsmodelle der Zukunft webbasiert zu gestalten.
Genau und jetzt aber um ganz kurz noch zum Abschluss zu bringen, wie wie das genau funktioniert. Das heißt, da kommt ein kommt also dieses Video kommt bei mir an
ist nochmal verschlüsselt, aber es ist vor mir verschlüsselt, so dass ich nicht in der Lage bin, das zum Beispiel mit jedem
Player, den ich möchte, abzuspielen, sondern in meinem Browser sitzt jetzt ein Plug-in, was sich von einem zweiten Server von einem Lizenzserver,
den Schlüssel zur Entschlüsselung dieses Videos holt. Das also auf einem anderen getrennten Kanal und dieser Austausch findet so statt,
dass es mir möglichst erschwert wird, diesen Schlüssel irgendwie mitzuschneiden. Das heißt also, in der Regel ist das so ein HTTPS. Das also
Ich habe ein Modul auf meinem Rechner, das erstmal guckt, ob es mit dem richtigen Server spricht, der eben mit dem richtigen Schlüsselserver und dann sagt, guck mal, ich bin hier der Nutzer und so und so und dann entscheidet der Lizenzserver,
ob er diesem Modul auch den Key für dieses Video gibt oder nicht. Und dieses ganze Modul muss möglichst so gebaut sein, dass es sich vor dem, dass es sich einer,
ähm einer äh Dissassenplierung oder einer einer einer Untersuchung durch den Nutzer ähm.
Entzieht, sodass es, weiß ich nicht, den Schlüssel nicht irgendwie einfach so in den Rahmen schreibt, sondern nochmal irgendwie manipuliert und allen möglichen Kram macht, der verhindern soll, dass Hacker
ähm dieses Modul dann halt analysieren
um ihm wiederum den Schlüssel zu entziehen und dann beispielsweise von von diesem gestreamten Video ähm eine Kopie anzufertigen, sondern es soll halt dadurch sichergestellt werden, dass der Nutzer immer nur so immer nur dann das Video,
sehen kann,
und wiedergeben kann, wenn ihm vorher das Recht dazu, von dem äh von dem Lizenzserver eingeräumt wurde. Und dieser Lizenzer kontrolliert ähm ja vermutlich dann Bezahlungseingänge oder.
Ja, wobei jetzt über diese konkrete Sicherheit dieser Applikation, diese Spezifikation nichts aussagt, könnte auch sehr unsicher sein, was es aber überhaupt erstmal erlaubt
ist äh die Trennung der Auslieferung, der eigentlichen Videodaten und eben das Entschlüsselungscodes
Das heißt, man kann auf einem ganz normalen CDN
Mediendateien offen per HTTP zugreifbar ohne gesonderte Sicherung und ohne große Autorisierung vorhalten und natürlich dann auch entsprechend replizieren und möglichst nah an die User ranbringen, ja? Äh,
und dann eben der eigentliche die eigentliche Berechtigung, diesen Content auch zu äh erlangen wird dann eben über diesen Weg,
hergestellt.
Und das ist aber, es gibt keinen sinnvollen Grund, dass also
Es gibt keinen anderen Grund, das zu tun, außer digitales Recht im Management, weil ich könnte genauso gut mein CDN mitm Zugriffsschutz versehen
Nutzer quasi auf der HTML-Seite dann sagen OK und wenn du dir das jetzt vom CDN holen möchtest, dann nutze bitte diese Zugangsdaten dafür.
Ne, also das ist keine also das ist keine andere denkbare Anwendung gibt, das würde ich jetzt nicht so sehen, also.
Nenne mir eine.
Die sind jetzt vielleicht etwas weit hergeholt, weil natürlich äh also wenn wir von DRM reden, reden wir ja auch vor allem äh primär von Vermarktung von Audio und Video, also Fernsehen und Filmen,
ja? Aber Video muss ja nicht unbedingt jetzt immer ein Hollywood-Movie sein, sondern das könnte ja zum Beispiel genauso gut auch irgend so ein,
Webcam, Überwachungskameras, Stream sein zum Beispiel.
Dessen, wo der Zugriff da drauf, dass du das sehen darfst sozusagen, von dem eigentlichen Strom entkoppelt sein könnte.
Ja, aber dann würdest du halt ähm.
Das könnt ihr dann auch sehr wohl in einem Browser äh passieren, wo das eben nicht nochmal gesondert gesichert ist.
Verstehe ich nicht. Also ich könnte also okay, na, sagen wir diese Webcam. Ähm.
Ist als Beispiel nicht sehr gut zu dem äh zu der Voraussetzung, dass dann die Mediendateien von einem CDM kommen, aber es ist halt grundsätzlich erstmal getrennt, wo verschlüsselst nicht
für den einen User das ganze Video, sondern es ist sozusagen generell,
und du kriegst dann aus der anderen Stelle halt den Key, um das eben äh auslesen zu können.
Genau, ich kriege den Key aber und das ist halt der, das ist halt das Geheimnis hier, ich kriege den Key so, dass ich ihn,
eigentlich nicht bekomme, sonst wäre ja das Problem, ähm sonst könnte ja jeder einmal den Key haben.
Und dann einfach das Video entsprechend umkurdieren und auf werfen oder so. Oder den den Key einfach twittern und jeder könnt's von Netflix dann gucken,
Ähm genau das soll eben nicht passieren, sondern ich bekomme den Key eben nicht. Sondern es wird versucht auf meinem Rechner
etwas zu zu konstruieren, was ich vollständig meiner Kontrolle entzieht. In Software geht das verständlicherweise nur bis zu einem gewissen Grade, also alle DAM-Softwaremaßnahmen wurden ja dann doch früher oder später mal ähm auseinandergenommen
Deswegen ist die aktuelle Entwicklung dahin, diese DRM-Teile sogar in die Hardware mit reinzugießen.
Sodass das quasi dann ein ein DRM-Modul sagen wir auf der auf dem auf dem Mainboard oder auf der Grafikkarte gibt,
in dem dann relevante Teile ähm vom Nutzer versteckt, entschlüsselt werden in in sicheren Bereich.
Sagen, den den die verschlüsselten Mediendaten einfach direkt in die Hardware rein, tut noch den Kita zu und dann kommt da irgendwie erst ein Bild bei.
Aber der Kies, der Kies, dann wiederum in der Hardware so drin, dass der Nutzer gar nicht mehr drankommt.
Ja. Na ja, also das äh ist sozusagen hier ganz klar äh das
das Ziel, ja, wenn man sich auch mal anschaut, wer diese Spezifikation macht, ist auch sehr interessant
Da ist nämlich einerseits Google äh vertreten mit einem Mitarbeiter Microsoft und die Firma Netflix in USA ja einer der
größten, wenn nicht sogar der größte Anbieter von ähm,
Videostreaming von Fernsehserien äh beziehungsweise Filmen. Und also quasi so eigentlich das Äquivalent zum Videoverleih äh auf digitaler Basis,
Die natürlich äh den Content von Hollywood eben nur mit der Auflage bekommen, dass sie entsprechende ähm.
Mechanismen auch sicherstellen.
Also es sind dann diese Scherze wie man darf das nur so und so. Man darf halt nur einmal gucken oder so, ne, solche.
Ja, beziehungsweise du mietest es halt und hast dann eben die Möglichkeit, das nur über einen bestimmten Zeitraum,
hinab zu werfen. Ich meine, man kann sich jetzt lange darüber streiten, ob's ob solche Modelle grundsätzlich verwerflich sind. Ja, da gibt's sicherlich äh verschiedene Meinungen dazu,
Weil wenn du sozusagen die Möglichkeit bietest, eben auch mit so einem Verwertungsmodell, dann kannst du natürlich auch ganz andere äh Preise realisieren.
Ja, um Kosten wieder einzuspielen. Ähm,
So oder so, gibt es aber jetzt äh Widerstand dagegen ähm von eben, wie gesagt, von der IF äh ausgehend und durchgeführt jetzt hier im Rahmen einer Petition von den Defective Bye Design,
genau ähm die halt der Meinung sind, sowas habe halt grundsätzlich in Vita drei C Standards nichts zu suchen.
Es hat halt in dem in dem HTML-Standard nichts zu suchen und da bin ich ähm also ich.
Wie gesagt, was sie im Prinzip, das schreiben sie, auch das hat hier überhaupt nichts mit DRM zu tun, das ist richtig, was sie eigentlich nur für äh also das Ganze nennt sich ja Incrypted Media Extensions, das heißt für
der Teil der Boateam L betroffen ist, ist hauptsächlich ähm dass.
Dass es zum HTML-Standard gehört eine adäquate Fehlermeldung rauszuwerfen, wenn man ein, wenn man nicht den Kie hat für dieses Video. Das heißt, ähm,
Also das wäre das, das ist quasi der der
der Standard, der hier fehlt, weil nichts hindert mich da schon heute daran, meine Videos verschlüsselt an den Nutzer zu werfen und von einem Browser Plugin zum Beispiel dafür sorgen zu lassen, dass sie entschlüsselt werden. Das Problem ist, dass der
Nutzer ähm dann irgendeine Fehlermeldung von seinem Player bekommt, dass diese Datei kaputt ist, weil.
Aber es geht natürlich auch dadrum dann das eben sozusagen für solche Systeme, die eben diese Methodiken nutzen, dass die äh auch eine
klare äh also es hier lässt sich ja aus dieser aus diesem Vorschlag lässt sich ja auch eine bestimmte Architektur ableiten, das ist ja auch
Teil dieser Spezifikation, wenn man in den Traft da reinschaut, gibt's da irgendwie eine schöne, dicke, äh große Grafik, wo das eben schön
aufgeteilt wird, äh wo die eigentlichen Kern Mediendaten herkommen und dann eben getrennt, der Leistungsserver quasi nochmal als Kelle äh Quelle für den Key
und äh die eben diese ausgelagerte Applikation, die den Browser ergänzt, ja, also ob das nun als Plug-in oder als separate Applikation mit der kommuniziert wird, da noch realisiert wird, seien wir da hingestellt
wie auch eben das die Modul, was auch nicht so.
Zwangsläufig Teil des Browsers sein muss, sondern eben Hardware-Software, was auch immer sein kann. Also diese Architektur, die zwar, wenn man jetzt draufschaut,
offensichtlich ist zur Implementierung von der eben aber immerhin ist ihm mal klar definiert plus eben des konkreten äh Eventverlaufs, der sich ergibt aus dieser Api-Spezifikation, wie sie eben jetzt hier in diesem Dokument mit drin steht.
Und damit ist halt klar
auf welche Architektur man sich stürzt, weil natürlich diese ganzen Unternehmen ein Interesse daran haben. Ich meine, wenn man sich's anschaut, was die Interessen sind, bei Netflix ist es klar, das ist halt jetzt heute schon äh ihr äh äh Business.
Und ähm interessant finde ich natürlich auch Google
ja, die dann äh dieser Spezifikation auch gleich so ein äh sogenanntes Non-Normittive Amantment hinzugeschrieben haben, was äh den Web M Standard betrifft, der ja noch vor kurzem als
die äh Lösung der Freiheit im Internet äh bejubelt wurde.
Übrigen genau von diesen Gruppen, die sich jetzt sozusagen äh dagegen wenden, also gegen diese Spezifikation wenden, nicht unbedingt gegen Web M. Sprich äh,
Google möchte gerne dann eben auch nebenbei gleich auch mal definieren, wie denn das ganz konkret aussehe, wenn halt hier Web M mit ins Spiel kommt. Äh gibt dann auch noch einen anderen,
äh anderes Emmentment, was hier auf irgend so einem obskures Isomedia Base-Fallformat bezieht, was von dem ich noch nie was gehört habe,
auffällig abwesend äh zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt in dieser Spezifikation des ja?
Wahrscheinlich zu neunundneunzig Komma neun neun neun Prozent des Medienformates, in dem äh DRM-Content heutzutage ausgeliefert wird.
Ja, aber da will ich halt nochmal kurz einhaken, weil so wie ich das sehe, ist das eigentlich völlig egal, was ich dann nachher in dieses Media-Element werfe
weil der Standard so ist, dass einfach gesagt wird, okay, das, was auch immer da kommt, muss einmal äh irgendwie durch das Content äh die und so würde ja auch so,
so muss ja auch die Spezifikation in HTML sein. Das ist nämlich erstmal völlig egal ist, was da was da durchkommt
und der Browser muss einfach nur wissen, was da ankommt, bevor ich das irgendwann irgendeinen Player gebe, muss ich das einmal durch das Model werfen, beziehungsweise hier als Anmerkung das Content äh Decription Modul
kann auch schon der Player sein, der muss gar nicht vom Player getrennt werden. Ähm was auch was auch so sinnvoll ist. Das Entscheidende ist, warum,
Also in dem in dem in dem in der,
gab es bisher keinerlei derartige Ideen. Es gab zu sagen, okay, wir können da irgendwie ein Flash-Element reinbauen und dieses Flash-Element konnte dann wieder allen möglichen Kram machen, ja?
Also nur weil's das bisher nicht gab, heißt das ja nicht, dass es das nicht geben könnte.
Ja genau, ist richtig, aber es es die Idee ist doch, dass es der ganzen Idee HTML oder der Punkt ist doch, dass er der ganzen Idee HTML widerspricht.
Wenn du irgendwie als wenn du hingehst, ja hier, man kann linken und den Inhalt einfügen und HTML zum Beispiel, die haben sich ja auch nie dagegen gewehrt, zu sagen, man man bindet zum per Eye Frame oder sonstwas, holt man sich Inhalte von einer anderen Domain oder sonstwas. Das war alles immer völlig offen.
Und jetzt.
Moin moin, also das ist auch ein klassisches Zusammenwerfen, ja, also HTML selbst sagt zum Beispiel über die Medien selbst gar nichts aus,
Das ist ja auch Teil gerade dieser Mediadebatte immer gewesen, ja, soll zum Beispiel äh definiert werden in diesem Standard, was der Inhalt ist und äh bis heute ist es halt so, nein, es gibt kein,
Format, was irgendwie als der Standard genannt wird. Also egal,
Ob es Opus oder Worbis oder äh was auch immer ist, auch Impact vier hat diesen Status nicht. Nichts ist sozusagen da definiert und das bleibt ja hier auch so.
Richtig, deswegen ist es ja deswegen aber das.
Man sagt nur, dass es eben dann auch spezifiziert wäre,
wie man an einen Key rankommt, wenn die Medieninhalte einbräuchten. Jetzt können wir natürlich noch darüber diskutieren,
Ob das jetzt generell evil ist, sowas zu spezifizieren, ja und ob das nun wirklich schon der Türöffner ist, wie es jetzt hier äh im Rahmen dieser Petition,
dargestellt wird.
Ähm.
Hängt es ja von den Implementierungen ab und von der Verfügbarkeit und so weiter.
Die Spezifikation geht aber noch nicht mal soweit zu sagen, wie der Nutzer jetzt an den Key kommt. Das ist nur, also was du hier als.
Ist eine AP.
Ja, aber das ist ein Beispiel. Also kannst natürlich auch komplett anders machen. Das kann ja auch von mir aus kann das halt über den, über deinen, von mir aus, über deinen, deinen neuen Personalausweis gehen, den Magnetkartenleser ziehst oder
Also da gibt's ähm aber das Entscheidende ist, dass im HTML-Standard eine Funktion vorgesehen ist, die es unterstützt
ähm eben nicht offen zu sein. Und wie gesagt, wenn man sagt, es geht um Verschlüsselung, das soll irgendwie sicher sein, dann äh ist das einfach auf dem falschen Layer
Und ähm die der einzige sinnvolle Anwendungsfall, also auch eine eine Zugangsbeschränkte
beschränkte Webcam würdest du halt anders lösen, nämlich über den, über eine Zugriffsbeschränkung auf die Webcam und nicht durch den,
den Zugriff auf das Video. Das Problem
wenn ich jetzt sage, okay, ich habe hier eine Webcam und man braucht Zugangsdaten dafür, ist wenn ich die irgendwie bei HTML übermittle, kann jeder diese Zugangsdaten nehmen und jedem anderen geben. Und genau das muss ja bei DRM verhindert werden, deswegen ist der einzige Anwendungsfall für dieses
Encrypted Media Element eben zu sagen ich will das unter Umständen gegen den Willen
selber machen, möchte den Nutzer damit dabei einschränken, äh wie er mit dem Inhalt, den ich ihm überschiebe,
umgeht und das ist bei HTML etwas komplett neues.
Naja, also ich fand ein anderes Beispiel ganz gut, ja, äh dieses äh wie verhindere ich das jetzt mein Video Telefonat nicht aufgezeichnet wird.
Genau, das hatten wir gerade. Ich weiß gar nicht, warte, glaube ich, noch im Vorgespräch. Ja.
Ne, ich meine, der Zugang zu dem eigentlichen,
Videostrom, ja? Äh klar kann ich den irgendwie sichern, aber das heißt lange nicht, dass äh so eine Büchse nicht auch nochmal irgendwie aufgehackt wird und du kannst dann halt sozusagen, du erhältst dann eben einen unverschlüsselten Videostrom und kannst den einfach
wegschreiben. So, wenn der jetzt erstmal so ist, machst du halt irgendwie Wege, hast die Zugriffsdaten, dann,
ist es sozusagen schon fertig und du kannst sofort restropieren. Wenn halt so ein DRM-artiges, Verschlüsselungs äh äh System aktiv ist, wird dir das ja erschwert.
So, man könnte jetzt argumentieren und das ist ja ich will jetzt hier weder,
Äh den, wie heißt das, äh Avocados, äh Diaboli, äh aktiv spielen, ähm noch hier irgendwas ähm.
Glorifizieren, was diese Lorifikation nicht äh verdient hat. Ich möchte nur mal bisschen versuchen, über die Box hinauszudenken, weil ja das, was DAM ermöglicht,
könnte grundsätzlich auch an vielen Stellen Privatsphäre sichern.
Das gilt ja zum Beispiel auch so für dieses meine Daten in den Händen anderer,
Ja, also wir sind immer besorgt dadrüber, wie ja unsere Daten, wie dann denn damit äh,
umgegangen wird, wenn sie woanders gespeichert werden, ja? Würde man sozusagen so ein DRM, so ein
Privacy äh DRM auf diese Daten drauflegen, nach dem Motto, ja, du darfst diese Daten der Kunden haben, darfst ja auch vorhalten, aber sie müssen äh verschlüsselt sein und wenn eine Applikation darauf zugreifen will, dann muss diese Applikation auch einen entsprechenden Key haben und
verstehst du? Also sozusagen Zugriff erhalten.
Du siehst, du siehst einen Anwendungsfall für die ähm.
Das liest sich damit auch machen, die Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Web-Grußbotschaft.
Also für die Webmailer, Videosbotschaft Ende zu Ende Verstöße. Das wird, glaube ich, damit irgendwie funktionieren.
Ja, stell dir mal vor, wir hätten jetzt so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Skype, Video, Skype irgendwie, was jetzt diese Technologie äh Skype ist vielleicht das falsche Beispiel, aber sagen wir mal so,
basierte Telefonie, das werden wir in Zukunft haben, ja, das wird irgendwann äh da sein und ich glaube,
Da sind wir auch gar nicht so weit von äh entfernt, diese Standards entstehen jetzt alle gerade und der Bedarf ist ohnehin schon da. Also du kannst im Web
äh jederzeit Leute anrufen, auf Facebook werden sich die Leute sozusagen direkt nicht nur äh bechatten, sondern eben auch per äh Telefonie und Videotelefonien miteinander verbinden und das ist alles sehr hoch privat.
Ja, aber das ist, dafür würdest du halt dran auf einen Transportlehrer gehen und SSL machen und ich glaube kaum.
Ja, aber das ist sozusagen nur der Weg, ja, aber dass die Daten auch noch bei dem Gegenüber dort ankommen und dass man zumindest versucht.
Verhindern, dass der das.
Weiterreichend, genau. Äh zu verhindern, ja, dass man das nicht total sicherstellen kann. Das ist das eine, aber das man doch erheblich erschweren kann, das ist das andere
und an der Stelle muss man
darüber zumindest mal nachdenken, bevor man gleich wieder die Empörungsflagge hisst und sagt, äh das ist äh alles böse und riecht nach Lulu, äh,
das darf nicht sein, weil es nicht sein darf, weil am Ende hängt's nicht von dieser Spezifikation ab, ob wir solche Technologien bekommen, sondern äh wie es letztlich umgesetzt und akzeptiert wird.
Ja, ich, äh, das, wir haben hier grade kurz darüber gerätselt, warum ist Google da drin? Das wäre so eine so eine Beispielanwendung wäre das, Google sagt hier, also ich glaube, es gibt dieses Google-Hangout und das
ist hier irgendwie webbasierter webbasierte Videokommunikation und Google könnte jetzt theoretisch hingehen und sagen, wir machen da, wir werfen da irgend so ein DRM drüber, um zu verhindern oder um um eine Maßnahme zu ergreifen, die den,
deinem Gesprächspartner erschwert das Gespräch aufzuzeichnen.
Das Gespräch.
Damit du sagen kannst, wir führen zwar hier ein kurzes Videogespräch über Google, ähm trotzdem.
Achten wir dabei darauf, dass dass das Gespräch irgendwie unter uns bleibt und ich nicht aufgezeichnet bin bei dem Gespräch. Das wäre so ein Beispiel,
massiver Overhead für Google den ganzen Scheiß nochmal äh individuell DRM zu äh mit DRM zu versehen, um nur um zu verhindern oder nur zu um zu erschweren, dass dein Gegenüber das aufzeichnet, der,
App, das du sowieso dann wieder hinkriegst.
Nee, nee, der Aufwand ist jetzt nicht enorm. Der Aufwand ist eigentlich relativ gut zu vertreten, weil mir ja sowieso
für eine sehr kleine Gruppe äh äh von Leuten auf einem Rechner der Aufwand getrieben wird, dieses Video überhaupt erstmal zu erzeugen, ist dann dann auch gleich noch mit zu verschlüsseln, ist jetzt nicht so das Problem.
Ist aber irgendwie nicht Googles Hauptinteresse.
Ich meine, jetzt können wir natürlich gleich auch wieder die Gegenkeule rausholen und sagen, wenn ich das aufzeichnen will, dann stelle ich halt eine Kamera vor meinen Bildschirmen und äh nimm den Ton auf und äh fertig ist die Laube.
Dann haben wir demnächst, dann haben wir demnächst auf nicht mehr die, sondern die Screenrips, wo die Leute ihre Webcam so im perfekten Abstand vor ihren iMac positionieren und das Video wieder abfilmen, das wird spannend.
Das ist schon noch immer eine eine andere Dimension. Trotz alledem ähm die,
Diese Debatte Privatsphäre von also Privatsphäre oder sagen wir mal äh Privacy trifft's glaube ich irgendwie besser oder? Ich weiß nicht, also so
sensitive persönliche Daten, das ist das, was ich meine, ja? Sozusagen die Verarbeitung derer, wenn sie woanders gespeichert werden müssen, wenn es sozusagen erforderlich ist oder man sich zumindest drauf geeinigt hat, das zu tun, an der Stelle eben mit
äh DAM-ähnlichen Maßnahmen den Umgang damit äh zu steuern in einem
Rahmen oder sagen wir mal die beliebige Nutzung zu erschweren oder zumindest besser zu kontrollieren. Ähm die würde ich gerne mal geführt sehen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich sehe da den einzigen Unterschied ist, also der Unterschied zwischen einer Privatsphäre, Maßnahme und einer DM-Maßnahme ist eben, dass ich bei der Privatsphäremaßnahme den Schlüssel kenne und bei einer DAM Maßnahme nicht, aber ich
erkenne an, dass es eine ähm.
Das ist sehr ähnliche Technologien sind, nämlich beide Male, beide Male eine Verschlüsselung und das ist unter Umständen es für den zu einer einfacheren zu einer vereinfachten Nutzung für den,
Für eine vereinfachten Anwendung für den Nutzer führen könnte,
Wir sind es aber glaube ich auch beide darüber einig, dass das vermutlich nicht das ist, was den den Schreibern dieses Standards als erstes in den Sinn gekommen.
B, das glaube ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt. Also das Netflix jetzt so an der,
front äh der äh Privatsphärenbewegung arbeiten würde, das wäre dann äh Neuigkeit für mich, Google zumindest hat äh gerne mal den Eindruck äh erzeugen lassen. Microsoft ist da, glaube ich, auch verdachtsfrei.
Ganz kurz noch, ähm weil wir, weil wir ja viel darüber gesprochen haben, was es was es noch für andere Möglichkeiten gibt. Ein Argument, was man da, glaube ich, auch noch mit äh einführen muss, äh mit anbringen muss,
Argumente einführen, dass ähm.
Dass das durchaus äh schon auch eine Maßnahme sein kann, um HTML in seiner Relevanz zu halten,
um nicht um halt zu vermeiden, dass jeder jetzt irgendwie seinen eigenen bastelt,
Das ist also, dass man also sagt, ey Jungs, wenn wir unser HTML hier,
Wenn wir die Relevanz von HTML für das Internet äh sichern wollen, dann müssen wir nun mal dieses Problem jetzt auch adressieren. Und wenn wir es schon nicht für Text machen.
Dann machen wir's zumindest mal für Media Element.
Ich bin ganz froh, dass das erstmal nur für Media Element ist, weil das Gleiche können sie selbstverständlich auch
als Extension sagen, für was weiß ich das Paragraph Element in HTML und sagen der der Inhalt dieses ähm dieses Absatzes kommt nur verschlüsselt,
und da brauchst du halt das, da ist halt dann das DLM hinter von Springer, dass du überhaupt diesen Artikel lesen kannst,
relativ frei von Sinn, weil äh ich dann halt die Möglichkeit habe zu copy passen oder so, ne. Aber vielleicht kann man das ja.
Ja gegebenenfalls auch noch verhindert werden könnte. Nur der Punkt ist, an der Stelle da.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich jetzt nicht hyperventiliere.
Ich auch nicht, aber.
Äh der wir wissen alle, dass in dem Moment, wo man sein Angebot im Web, was ja immer in Konkurrenz steht zu allem anderen. Äh so weit reduziert, dass es irgendwie fast nicht mehr brauchbar ist, dass es dann einfach dazu führt, dass die Leute das nicht benutzen.
Das das.
Gerade bei Video äh und und ne.
Mir fällt nur noch ganz wichtig ein, dass halt äh du hattest ja auch gerade schon den den Vorgespräch. Den ihr seht, wir Tim und ich diskutieren ja schon länger drüber,
die die digitale Rechte Minderung wie wie DRM ja übersetzt wird, dass es insgesamt ein ein schlechten Beigeschmack hat, gerade in so einem offenen Standard wie HTML. Ähm,
Extensions hinzuzufügen, die dem Nutzer äh oder die die deren Haupt darin besteht, dem Nutzer die Kontrolle über das, was da geschieht, zu entziehen. Und diese,
nicht nur aus aus der aus so einer Anti-Urheberrechtsperspektive und aus einer Verbraucherschutzperspektive einen schlechten Ruf, sondern eben auch aus Sicht von ähm,
von sagen wir mal Leuten, die auf auf,
auf eine gewisse äh Hygiene acht geben bei der bei der bei der Nutzung ihres Gerätes, dass man eben da die Sachen unter Kontrolle haben möchte. Und das ist ein offener Standard
sich eben nicht vor mir versteckt und mich zwingt irgendwie da Sachen zu. Und das, das ich also immer unter Kontrolle habe, was in was mit meinem Gerät.
Ein offener Standard.
Und eine Implementierung von etwas und ob es Open ist oder nicht, also ob insbesondere ist oder nicht oder ob's von mir veränderbar ist oder nicht, sind schon nochmal ein paar andere Sachen und ich finde, du hast schon einen ganz guten Punkt gebracht, so dieses äh,
will man jetzt sozusagen fördern, dass äh noch mehr Systeme am Web vorbei äh entwickelt werden oder ähm schaffen wir sozusagen einen Weg. Ich meine,
die Realität ist auch, das Internet,
alles, ja? Und äh äh will alles abdecken und vor allem will das Web eben einen Großteil davon abblicken, zumal eben das Web einen zunehmenden Maße, das ist ja auch nichts Neues,
Ort ist, auf dem unsere Anwendung basieren, Programme sprechen, Web,
um alles mögliche zu tun und äh natürlich,
auch dieser Videoteil und warum soll man dann nicht irgendwie diesen Quatsch, auch wenn man ihn ablehnt, da einfach spezifizieren, ja, damit das zumindest von seinem Verhalten her klar ist.
Aber du du sagst ja schon, okay.
Verwendet wird, ist dann immer noch eine andere Sache.
Programme sprechen, Web, du meinst, also Programme sprechen, HTTP oder Programme sprechen HTML oder
XML äh um um über ihre äh zu kommunizieren und das war ja immer das Spannende, das ist alles offen, dieses Web und der da die große,
Die ganz große Sache, in meinen Augen war, äh, war nicht, nicht HTML, sondern eben RSS. Ja, da, dass man sagt, okay, wir trennen ähm oder eigentlich.
CSS und und RSS, so die beiden Sachen, nämlich Cascating Stylesheets, wir trennen einmal den Inhalt vom vom Design und er ist wir trennen wirklich mal vollständig den wir nehmen nur den Inhalt und machen ihn Maschinen lesbar, ja?
Und es gibt dann konkret auf der anderen Seite, dass das CSS, so dass ich aus dem ESS fehlt mir die die Webseite meines Interesses im komplett anderen Design bauen kann, ja? Das war das war so die Freiheit. Und dann gab dann gab's diese und da haben konnte man dann sogar noch eine App
drum rum machen, um diesen Inhalt und musste sich noch nicht mal mehr auf die Restriktion Webseite äh beziehen. So, genau, was passiert? Äh,
Twitter verteilt über ihre verteilen über ihre Application Keys und ähm und wir haben auf einmal alle oder einen Podcast, der die ganze Zeit nur noch von App dot net redet. Ja, aber da wird wird quasi diese schöne,
Webtechnologie, die so offen und frei ist und was ja auch die Stärke war, nach und nach eben,
eingeschwächt ja und eingeschränkt. Und wie gesagt, die die Apis werden zugemacht oder kontrollieren und es werden immer längere äh Bedingungen geschrieben dafür, dass die APD überhaupt noch antwortet,
und jetzt auch noch DRM im äh Dingens und.
Würde nicht sagen.
Keine tolle Entwicklung.
Also ich meine jetzt machst du nochmal ein anderes Fass auf mit dieser ganzen äh AP-Debatte, das ist auch sehr interessant, muss man vielleicht auch nochmal führen. Ähm nur sehe ich das jetzt nicht unbedingt so, dass Twitter,
das Web einschränkt, weil das Web erstmal davon vollkommen,
unbeleckt ist. Ja, also du bist in dem Moment äh trittst du in einen Scheißetopf, wenn du dich halt mit Twitter einlässt. Ja, aber das beeinflusst ja keine andere Webseite.
Es findet halt nur über dieselben Standardswege und ähnliche Protokolle statt, was eben viele, viele Vorteile hat, Vorteile für deine Netzwerkkonfiguration, Vorteile für äh die Entwickler,
Ich sehe das nicht, dass das eine das andere sofort äh äh platt macht und ich sehe halt auch nicht,
Dass diese Spezifikation jetzt das größte Problem ist, äh was wir haben. Ja, weil die,
Präsenz dieser Spezifikation erstmal gar nichts ändert. Ja, sondern du hast dieselbe Software, die es jetzt heute auch schon gibt und dieselben Businessmethoden, die es heute auch schon gibt, dann eben äh.
Auf HTML aufsetzen. Gut, ändert nichts da dran, ja?
Derzeit ist es halt nur eine ab in deinem Gerät.
Na ja, also wir lassen das mal offen und da freuen wir uns auch über ähm Kommentare und andere Sichtweisen, weil ich glaube, das ist schon mal so auch eine Diskussion, die muss man mal ähm führen und.
Wir hatten uns ja mal vorgenommen, hier sehr unaufgeregt äh an die Themen ranzugehen. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob uns das im letzten Jahr immer so äh.
Jetzt eigentlich relativ unaufgeregt, aber man muss sie.
Sehr unaufgeregt, das wollte ich nämlich auch gerade sagen, also jetzt kommen wir sozusagen mal wieder hier zu unserem Ursprung äh zurück kurz bevor wir hier anderthalb Jahre vollmachen. Ähm,
und Regen auch äh entsprechend unaufgeregte äh Diskussionen an. Hoffentlich.
Jo. Nächstes Thema.
Super. Nächstes Thema. Genau, nächstes Thema.
Ist was? Hammer?
Filesharing for the Greator good. Das ist nur eine Kurzmeldung. Ähm inzwischen gibt's ja so viele Studien, ähm,
Die den äh die den,
fürchterlichen äh die Kultur erodierenden Effekt des illegalen nicht nachweisen können und ähm,
Diesmal war's eine Studie der EU-Kommission, wo also offensichtlich die Autorin das Memo nicht bekommen haben,
Und äh da hat die äh gemeinsame Forschungsstelle der EU Kommission äh eine
Ja, wie auch immer. Da gibt's jetzt irgend so ein sieben Institute, haben da irgendwie technologische Zukunftsforschung und Pipapo. Und sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt eine Studie über
äh den Konsum digitaler Musik im Internet veröffentlicht, haben irgendwie ganz viel Surfverhalten,
Angeschaut und kommt zu dem Schluss, dass die Ergebnisse darauf hindeuten, dass die äh sechzehntausend Probanden ähm.
Überwiegende Mehrheit der Musik nicht legal gekauft hätten, wenn sie sie nicht vor, wenn sie sie nicht vorher hätten illegal herunterladen können. Es ist also genau dieses Argument.
In Anführungsstrichen.
Illegal in Anführungsstrichen, ja. Weißt du, also genau dieses Argument, dass.
Preview.
Genau, dieses dieses Recht auf Preview und dieses diese Verkaufsförderung von Pirate Bayer. Ich weiß nicht, ob Pirate das immer noch macht, aber die hatten auch längere Zeit, um als ihr Logo dieses ähm The Promo-Bay. Dass sie, wo sie also gesagt haben, e.
Eier haben sie immer noch, ja, in in irgendwelche.
Seit ein paar Wochen, ne? Hm.
Ja, hatten sie schon mal früher, aber wie auch immer. Ähm sie bezeichnet sich also als und sagen, ja klar, wo wo hören denn die Leute eure Mucke? Ja, nirgendwo anders. Die können sie ja nur bei uns hören, weil ihr ja mit eurem DRM, ne. Okay, lassen wir das. Aber ähm.
Wobei sie dann YouTube-Videos einblenden, also es kann man schon auch noch woanders äh tun, ne.
Das ist schon genau das da kann man dann kritisieren.
Ja, aber es äh das ist schon ich meine, ich habe.
Interessant.
Das ist nicht die erste Studie, die zu diesen Ergebnissen kommt. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch nie äh was anderes, die jetzt nicht unmittelbar von der Rechteindustrie selber äh forciert worden wäre.
Ist Google damit drin, wegen YouTube. Weil YouTube doch auch in das Fernsehgeschäft gehen will und die Live-Übertragung und so. Das war mir nicht klar, ich du hast mich mit deinem Google Hango Privatsphäre Argument komplett äh.
Ja, natürlich ist das das Ding und Google, äh, ich meine, ich ich.
Na ja, genau, YouTube gibt's auch noch.
Ich habe mich damals schon immer gewundert, so als als YouTube von Google gekauft wurde. Ja, gab's auch so, ja, was wollen die denn damit? Ich so, Leute, das,
Fernsehen, das ist das Fernsehen der Zukunft und die machen sich einfach zum größten Fernsehsender der Welt und genau das ist es halt
auch äh äh geworden, ne? Und äh man sieht ja auch, wie sehr YouTube davon profitiert hat, dass man da alles sehen kann,
Ja? Und wir haben uns auch schon extrem daran gewöhnt und das ist ja hier auch in dieser GEMA-Debatte immer das Problem, ja? Ich meine, irgendwie das nicht akzeptiert.
Dass man diesen Content nicht erst mal sieht.
Ja? Und äh das nicht unbedingt sozusagen auch sofort so als kommerziellen Vorgang empfindet. Genauso ist so dieses erstmal reinhören. Ich meine das ist so ein bisschen was machst du, wenn du in eine Bücherei gehst?
Und dir ein Buch äh aussuchst, guckst du ja nur das Cover an, denkst du schönes Cover.
Ich gehe zum Kopierer.
Das kaufe ich jetzt mal. Nee, du fängst anderen zu blättern, ja. Du liest da ein bisschen was und und äh.
Auch so ein Fotobildband blätterst du durch, hast wahrscheinlich jedes Foto irgendwie schon mal gesehen und dann
war's das oder was? Und dann gehst du irgendwie jeden Tag in die in die Bücherei und blätterst die Fotobände durch und dann hast du was. Nein, das ist ein anderes Produkt. Das Produkt heißt hier kannst du's auch,
Mit nach Hause nehmen und dann kannst du da immer drin blättern. In dieser spezifischen Form so, ja?
Ja, also was, was bei dieser ganzen Musiksache eben die Rolle spielt, ähm ich kaufe ja äh mir sehr, sehr selten Musik,
Und wenn, dann ähm kaufe ich die,
kaufe ich sie dann auch auf Vinyl oder so. Deswegen begrüße ich zum Beispiel dieses Angebot, dass Amazon jetzt irgendwie sagt, kaufst du Vinyl, kriegst du MP3 dazu, finde ich super. Ähm aber.
Was dieses Preview-Argument angeht, ne, ähm dass man sagt, okay ähm ne, bei Pirate Bay runtergeladen und dann gekauft, ja, oder dass ja auch der.
Bei Pirat Bay kannst du es ja schöner äh schöner Weise diese Lengschnittstudien machen. Das heißt, du kannst quasi sehen, du hast einmal die Zeitleiste der Verkäufe und dann hast du die
Aber gleichzeitig kannst du live auf sehen, wie viele äh wie
beliebt das ist. Und es ist ja so, dass es beliebt wird und dann gekauft wird, ja? Das heißt also, du hast da, kannst da tatsächlich durch die zeitliche Abfolge äh zumindest ein äh ein Zusammenhang naheliegend sehen.
Muss auch nur hier auf Torent Freak äh gucken, ja, dieses äh Blog, was ich so Torentnews äh immer mehr, die haben dann immer so diese Statistiken, so Most Tower Stuff im Monat sowieso oder im Jahr auch, äh,
und habe mir das jetzt nicht jedes Mal akribisch äh angeschaut, aber mein Eindruck war bisher immer das, was da,
Am meisten kopiert wird, ist auch das, was am meisten kommerziellen Erfolg hat.
Ja, aber das ist ähm das ist ein Argument, was ja von Seiten der Rechteinhaber sehr äh leicht zu widerlegen ist, dass sie sagen, ja klar, wenn die Leute das viel kaufen.
Kein Argument der Gerichte inhaber.
Oder doch natürlich, so genau das, sie nehmen genau diesen, diesen Sachverhalt und sagen, klar, wenn das viel wenn das viel gekauft wird, wird's auch viel geklaut.
Hätte es ja noch mehr verkauft werden können. Genau. Sozusagen. Ja gut, aber die Argumentation muss andersrum laufen.
Na ja, darüber streiten sie sich jetzt seit vielen, vielen Jahren. Das das Interessante ist also diese man muss den zeitlichen Zusammenhang sehen. Ja, geht's erst bei Pirate Bay hoch und dann die Verkäufe oder geht das zeitgleich hoch oder.
Und dann die Pirate Sachen.
Dass äh wenn etwas überhaupt äh per Fallsharing verfügbar ist, dass es dann dazu beiträgt, dass man damit kein Geld mehr verdienen kann. So und das kann man eigentlich diesen Statistiken auch schon sehr gut entnehmen.
Das ist nicht äh ja.
Vor allem auch, dass äh wenn jetzt mal so independent Filme, wie es noch gleich hier dieser südafrikanische äh Science Fiction, äh der mal so total oder so.
Keine Ahnung. Nee.
Kennst du gar nicht? Ja, so, weißt du, so ich meine, Science-Fiction aus Südafrika, dreht sich auf der Straße jetzt keiner äh um, wenn du irgendwie sagst, äh äh das könnte man sich doch auch mal anschauen, ne?
Nein, komme ich gerade nicht drauf. Und ähm.
Der ist halt im Netz entdeckt worden, quasi. Dadurch ist der so äh bekannt geworden und ist dann in der Folge eben auch ein kommerzieller Erfolg geworden, weil es einfach das Ganze verstärkt hat.
Hm, ja.
Gucken, ob ich den Namen richtig habe. Ich bin durcheinander.
Also die die Studien auf jeden Fall sagen äh oder es ist ein eine erneute Studie, da gibt's ja schon mehrere äh,
die also sagen, okay, diese ähm dieses Argument, dass das dass da irgendwie wirklich wirtschaftlicher Schaden entsteht und so, dafür finden wir einfach keine Grundlage und das ist auch nicht die erste Studie, die das so sagt. Ähm,
Spannend ist, dass dann natürlich hier äh äh Spotify sich dann zu Wort meldet und sagt, äh ja ähm
Aber was ist denn hier mit mit unserem Service, ne? Weil eigentlich könnten wir doch diese ähm könnten wir mit unserem legalen äh Angebot ja ähm.
Diese Promo-Funktion von Pirate Bay ersetzen und möchten die gerne für uns reklamieren. Interessanterweise da äh wird da also ähm,
Spotify ähm auch,
spannenderweise dann so zum Gegner der der Fall, ne? Und wollen also sagen, hier genau diese Promofunktion, das ist doch eigentlich unser Argument,
und die
geringen Lizenzgebühren von den Labels haben wollen. Also auch Spotify hat kein Interesse mehr daran. Äh da eine eine Konkurrenz zu haben, die ein besseren, besseren Service anbietet. Es bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend und,
Ich find's auf jeden Fall zumindest so viel können wir festhalten, dass es wichtig äh.
Bei den Schwierigkeiten für Spotify äh jemals Geld zu verdienen, wundert mich das auch nicht.
Ja okay.
Weil die werden wiederum von den Rechteinhabern so kurz gehalten, dass also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das wirklich mal zum Erfolg äh geführt wird, eigentlich naja, gering ist.
Machen wir jetzt auf jeden Fall großes Fass aufmachen, aber wie gesagt, merkt euch, es gibt viele Studien, die äh widerlegen
dass das in großartigen wirtschaftlichen Schaden hervorruft und dass
sind dann meistens die Studien, die methodisch sauber durchgeführt wurden und von unabhängigen Forschern und wo nicht irgendwie ein Beratungsunternehmen hinter sitzt, äh was im Auftrag eines äh
eines äh Content äh einer Content Konglumerates
da diese Studie in Anführungszeichen durchgeführt in Anführungszeichen, hat in Anführungszeichen.
Genau, wir waren nämlich schon immer, wir waren nämlich noch nie im Krieg mit Oasien. So, weiter geht's.
Ja, nur eine ganz kurze Meldung, da gibt's eigentlich nur kurz Zahlen. Äh der Bericht über Abhörungsmaßnahmen des Bundesnachrichtendienstes wurde mal wieder vom Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium,
veröffentlicht und ähm da gab's da gibt's eine schöne Zahl ähm und zwar muss man sich das so vorstellen, es gibt dieses Artikel zehn Gesetz, das Gesetz zur Beschränkung des Brief, Post und Fernmeldegeheimnisses ähm.
Von.
Ich weiß nicht genau, äh muss ich jetzt gucken, woher, ne? Es heißt Artikel zehn Gesetz und es ist der Artikel,
Es heißt tatsächlich die Artikels hingesetzte, selbst sogar auf ähm auf welcher Hand?
Artikel zehn Gesetz. Gesetz zur Beschränkung des Briefpost- und Fernmeldegeheimnisses. Artikel zehn gesetzt, ja. In dem es dann eben darum geht, unter welchen äh Bedingungen äh Verfassungsschutz.
Also es bezieht sich auf Artikel zehn des der Verfassung. Ja, genau. Ja, okay. Mhm.
Ja, genau. Ähm.
Näheres regelt ein Bundesgesetz.
Und äh da dieses sagte also unter welchen Bedingungen Verfassungsschutz äh militärischer Abschirmdienst, Bundesnachrichtendienst und so äh auf Telekommunikation und äh die dem die dem Brief und Postgeheimnis unter Licht zugreifen kann.
Darf. Und was sie haben, ist ja,
Schon die Schnittstellen bei den äh bei den Providern oder den größeren Providern, ähm ganz klar, geben sie darüber auch keine Auskunft, wo sie die genau haben, wobei da äh wie gesagt sich durchaus ähm,
Hinweise dass das,
das Wissen eigentlich schon durchaus auf der die Spatzen pfeifen ist von den Dächern, sagen wir mal wo diese äh wo diese Geräte stehen.
Ähm und was sie da haben, ist so eine, sie haben irgendwie so eine Art Höchstgrenze und bekommen,
automatisch nehmen sie dann zufällig einen gewissen Anteil der Kommunikation raus und schmeißen den durch so eine automatische Texterkennung und die wiederum äh,
schmeißt dann äh am Ende was waren das jetzt dreihundert Millionen nee, drei Millionen äh E-Mail-Verkehre raus. Im Jahr zweitausendelf und ähm.
Da steht dann irgendwas drin, nach irgendwelchen Regeln, die die natürlich nicht öffentlich sind und ähm dann gibt's eine weitere Untersuchung ähm.
Ob das jetzt auch nachrichtendienstlich relevant ist. Und das ist also wirklich so eine fast drei Millionen, wurden abgehört, dass es einer alle fünf Sekunden,
ähm und dann wurde es irgendwie dann,
denkt man, also entweder ist das internationaler Terrorismus, Verdacht auf internationalen Terrorismus, Verdacht auf äh Prolieferation und konventionelle Rüstung oder Verdacht auf illegale Schleusung, das sind so die Themenbereiche
um die, die sich kümmern. Und am Ende gibt's dann irgendwie null Komma null eins Prozent, also zweihundertneunzig.
Rüstung, Schleusung, was war das Erste?
Terrorismus. Ähm und da gibt's am Ende zweihundertneunzig, die sie als nachrichtendienstlich relevant einstufen. Dafür haben sie halt diese gesamten diese riesige Überwachungsinfrastruktur.
Zweihundertneunzig relevante von ungefähr zwei Komma neun Millionen.
Die sie abgeschnorchelt haben.
Das heißt, so ein Verhältnis von eins zu äh zehntausend, wenn ich das jetzt richtig.
Ja, aber du musst ja dann noch gucken, dass ähm,
Anteil, naja okay, muss man dann überlegen, aber es ist unklar, wie sie, warum sie die drei Millionen abgehört haben, ja oder,
Und diese irgendwie durch ihren Wortfilter und so. Da geben sie natürlich keine genaue Auskunft drüber. Was was man also auf jeden Fall scheint die Auswahl eher ihnen zu obliegen.
Auch technisch, was sie sich jetzt genauer anschauen. Mit anderen Worten, wenn diese Auswahl ihnen obliegt, dann bekommen sie erstmal alles.
Genau, das heißt, es gibt eigentlich keine Kontrolle im eigentlichen Sinne.
Nicht wirklich, außer halt einen Bericht, der dann eben anderthalb Jahre später erscheint und wo gesagt wird, ja, drei Millionen.
Millionen. Also so zehntausend Abhörmaßnahmen pro Tag.
Ja, Fun fact, ähm es gibt ähm,
Es gibt eine es gab einen Peak irgendwie im Jahr zweitausendzehn, da waren das irgendwie sehr, sehr viel mehr, nämlich dreimal so viele
Ähm da hatten sie ihre Auswahl Algorithmus irgendwie nicht ganz im Griff und haben relativ viel Spam äh.
So so.
Ja
OK also man kann da jetzt wenig mit anfangen, dass in ich denke was man sich merken muss ist es gibt natürlich diese diese automatisierten Schnittstellen wo die die Dienste wie man so schön sagt dranhängen
und es gibt relativ wenig Kontrolle darüber, nach welchen Kriterien die eure Kommunikation durchwühlen und ähm.
Spamen wir auch mal eine schöne Idee. Also wenn man sozusagen ohnehin das Gefühl hat, man würde überwacht werden, dann kann man ja dann sozusagen seine überwachten Kommunikationsleitungen.
Die ganze Zeit im Betrieb halten, mit so fertigen CDs oder so,
Ja, also stell dir mal vor, du telefon lässt einfach dein Telefon, telefonieren und spielst dann so Werbebotschaften darüber ab.
Ja, mal gucken, wie lange äh wie lange der wie lange du das machst, bis dir das keinen Spaß mitmacht. Also ich.
Die Frage ist, wie lange ist denn BND dann noch macht, bis denen keinen Spaß mehr macht.
Im Zweifelsfall einfach nur als Argument nehmen, sich eine dickere Anlage dahinzustellen, ne?
Ja und dann müssen sie Spam-Filter installieren muss. Na ja, man man schafft halt sozusagen mehr Neues.
Schreibt eure.
Dann so.
Eure Terror-Emails über äh übers Open Spam Relays, ja?
Die werden dann also,
Interessanter Punkt ist eigentlich diese Zahlen, die sind sowieso jenseits von Gut und Böse und ähm ich denke, die einzige Information, die man da,
raus, die man ja rediabel rausnehmen kann ist, dass diese Infrastruktur existiert, dass sie keiner nennenswerten Kontrolle unterliegt und dass selbstverständlich bei jedem größeren Provider.
Auch die entsprechenden Gerätschaften im Schrank stehen, ja, um genau das zu ermöglichen. Und ähm,
Das äh muss dann jeder für sich selber wissen, wie wie da wie man damit umgeht. Wie gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, dass eine äh die Nutzung von Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung da ähm nach wie vor,
eine äh entscheidende Rolle spielen sollte für jeden, äh der sich in Sachen,
Privatsphäre interessiert oder eben im internationalen Terrorismus und konventionelle Rüstung oder bei in illegaler Schleusung sein Geschäftsmodell in dieser unserer Gesellschaft sieht.
Gut, damit sind wir eigentlich auch schon fast äh am Ende. Vielleicht sollten wir noch einen kleinen Ausblick äh auf die äh uns doch zumindest vielfältig beschäftigen beschäftigende,
Veranstaltungen, Republika äh werfen,
Nummer dreizehn, haben jetzt noch ein paar äh Ausgaben hier unserer Sendung, bis es dann soweit ist, aber es macht zu den Eindruck, als ob das Programm jetzt halbwegs also es ist, glaube ich, noch nicht komplett,
ziert, aber äh es es füllt sich. Ähm wer das also noch nicht getan hat, sollte dann nochmal draufschauen und mal erwägen, da vielleicht hinzukommen, warum
abgesehen davon, dass viel zu viele Leute, mit denen wir irgendwie mehr oder weniger regelmäßig irgendwas zu tun haben, da mehr oder weniger vollständig herumlaufen, fand ich die Entwicklung der Republika in den letzten Jahren an sich,
sehr gut. Ähm ist wirklich 'nen.
Spannendes ähm Ereignis. Einerseits vom Vortragsprogramm her, wo man jetzt nicht alles mögen äh äh kann und muss ähm,
wo aber auch immer wieder gute Sachen dabei sind, also auch deshalb lohnt es sich, aber es ist natürlich vor allem ein Treffpunkt, wie das bei allen Veranstaltungen ist,
mit einem sehr hohen Quote an interessanten Leuten. So sehe ich das. Siehst du das ähnlich?
Ja ähm sowohl unter den Vortragenden als auch unter den Anwesenden.
Genau, also da ist viel zu holen und von daher wollen wir euch da auch ermuntern, drüber nachzudenken, daran teilzunehmen. Wir werden da sein, wir werden äh sicherlich immer ansprechbar sein,
Also für die Linus dann nochmal ein Bier ausgeben will, da ist auf jeden Fall,
Gelegenheit, Kinderhorn, solange er noch gehen kann, ja, schiebt ihn wieder zur Bar zurück. Das wünscht mir doch immer.
Ja, inzwischen äh äh ist.
Könnte es auch mal was anderes sein, also auch Müsliriegel sind gern gesehen.
Zwischendurch könnt ihr mir mal ein Wasser bringen,
Nee, genau, also Republika, feine Sache, wird wird schön und ähm ich.
Talken.
Ja, ich habe ich habe einen äh einen kleinen kurzen Vortrag, den ich da halten werde. Äh überhaupt nichts mit Netzpolitik zu tun. Und zwar äh werde ich ähm über Refi versprechen,
Ähm der Vortrag hat den Titel Refi für Erkenntnisse der empirischen Treuforschung und da konnte ich äh den Michael Krey von Open Data City als äh mit Vortragenden gewinnen und auch noch,
weitere Personen, mit denen wir gerade die ganzen Sachen anschauen und ähm.
Muss vielleicht mal kurz sagen, was Rehpfiffe ist.
Ach muss ich das echt erzählen? Nee, dat.
Äh weiß nicht, ob das jeder weiß. Das, ich vermute, dass das nicht jeder weiß.
Refiff ist eine eine Plattform, die äh das Blog von Fefe mit,
einer Kommentarfunktion versieht und ist erreichbar unter Blog Punkt ReFE Punkt DE und ähm zeichnet sich insbesondere dadurch aus, dass ich äh glaube ich, seit ich sie gebaut habe,
vielleicht äh.
Eine einstellige Anzahl an Kontrollen vorgenommen habe, was da so kommentiert wird und ähm deshalb, glaube ich, bei vielen Leuten als sehr äh frei,
gilt, was äh sie da so an Meinungen kundtun können.
Und das äh wirkt sich durchaus auch auf die äh Kommentarqualität dort aus. Ähm.
Mhm. Ähm gibt's schon einen Termin für den Talk?
Ich habe den jetzt im Fahrplan noch nicht gesehen, aber ich habe die äh es wurde auf jeden Fall angenommen. Also kann man sich mal anschauen unter Blog Punkt Refi DE, wer da einmal irgendwo in die äh Kommentarspalte schaut,
wird schnell sehen, dass sich da durchaus einige,
Sachen zu sagen lassen, durchaus vielleicht also wenn der interessanten Kombination aus psychologischer Perspektive und aus der Perspektive einer Person, die sich mit sehr
mit großen Datensätzen auseinandersetzen kann, denn Refi verfügt inzwischen, glaube ich, über so irgendwas hundertfünftausend
Kommentare, die da äh angefallen sind bisher. Und ich glaube, dass wir da äh einige lustige Analysen äh haben
die wir äh mit dem Publikum teilen werden, wofür uns vom republika Team dreißig Minuten eingeräumt wurden. Dir wurde ein ganzer Raum gegeben für vier Tage oder so, habe ich gehört.
Nee. Ich bin, nee, ich bin noch nicht mal, äh ich bin noch nicht mal in Saal eins, was mir ehrlich gesagt ganz recht ist.
Noch nicht mal in Salat.
Letztes Jahr war ich da. Letztes Jahr war ich der war ich sozusagen der äh eingestellt äh,
Leute aus dem Bett holen, erster Talk des zweiten Tages
das kann ich jetzt so schlecht nicht gemacht haben, weil ich bin wieder der erste Talk des zweiten Tages, allerdings dann halt im im Saal zwei, das ist mir ehrlich gesagt äh schnurz, ich fand den Saal als auch etwas,
sehr groß.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer was jetzt seit zwei oder Saal eins ist oder.
Ja, Sat1 war dir da ganz ganz hinten.
Ja genau, aber ich mache nie die Aufteilung wieder gleich.
Das weiß ich nicht so genau, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich in dem Vortragsraumkonzept zumindest was die großen Säle betrifft, nicht viel ändert, weil da wirst du jetzt nicht sehr
vier Varianz äh einführen können, so wie das Gebäude dort ist. Äh keine Ahnung, ich lasse mich überraschen, ist mir auch egal. Äh ich bin ganz
zufrieden mit dem Slot, finde das gut. Zweiter Tag früh ist äh ein guter Kompromiss, weil gleich als allererstes starten ist auch immer doof, weil man dann ähm so recht die Atmosphäre des äh Events noch nicht so eingeatmet hat,
auch selber noch nicht so äh also mir geht es zumindest so, ich muss das irgendwie alles erstmal so ein bisschen verdauen.
Ist der zweiter Tag morgens ist der beste Slot, weil da kommen dann auch alle.
Das weiß also da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, weil eigentlich schon ab ersten Tag geht das ja los mit diesen Diskussionen bis äh Ende. Letztes Jahr war ja so super Wetter, weißt du, bis da standen sie ja noch bis dreiundzwanzig Uhr noch aufm Hof rum. Meinst du.
Aber gutes Wetter gibt's ja dieses Jahr nicht. Gut, ach gutes Wetter. Es wird dieses gesamte Jahr.
War fast immer gutes Wetter.
Ja, aber zweitausenddreizehn gibt's einfach kein gutes Wetter. Das hat jetzt nichts mit der Republika zu tun, aber Wetter äh fangen wir nicht mit dem Wetter an. Also Wetter ist scheiße.
Ja, ein Wetter.
Wenn wir Glück haben, regnet's nicht.
Wetter-Podcast. Das ist noch eine echte Marktlücke.
Fragen.
Ja. Komm hier, ich komme. Wir machen das mal. Ah, ich glaube, der ist äh ausreichend medienvoll. Wie auch immer, ähm ja.
Ja. Aber was ist denn jetzt mit deinem Raum? Du hast doch einen ganzen Raum da.
Ach so, ja, vielleicht noch mal kurz zum Talk, also äh ich rede, wie es nicht anders zu erwarten war, über Radio,
Und ähm will mal so ein bisschen äh zusammenfassen, was im letzten Jahr so aus meiner Sicht äh sich bewegt hat,
ansprechen, aber auch generell mal eher so eine Vision darstellen, wie ich mir das eigentlich alles so vorstelle mit dem Radio,
und der Zukunft und im Internet und der Gesellschaft und und der Community und all dem. Äh ja,
und ansonsten mache ich ja am Wochenende vorher, ist schon ausgebucht äh so ein Podcaster Workshop
das heißt, es werden sowieso viele Podcaster aus Deutschland so nach Berlin kommen und ich hoffe, dass viele dann auch die Gelegenheit nutzen werden, dann gleich bei der Republika auch zu sein,
Ähm und äh wir werden dann sozusagen vom Projekt her ähm.
Auch einen permanenten Workshop Raum haben auf der Republika,
wo man dann, das muss jetzt im Detail alles noch geplant werden, aber wo die Idee ist, dass man da eben auch Sendungen aufnehmen kann, also es ist einfach so ein so ein Ort gibt, wo man.
Machen kann, also wo man wirklich publizieren kann, wo man von dieser Veranstaltung her
berichten kann, also wenn Podcast da vor Ort sind, müssen die dann nicht
ihr eigenes Equipment mit Rumtragen, das können sie natürlich auch gerne tun, wenn sie mehr so mobil aufzeichnungs business unterwegs sind, weil da sozusagen so ein Tisch bauen
eben allen ermöglicht, da mal eine Sendung aufzunehmen,
und auch überhaupt äh ein Anlaufpunkt zu sein für Leute, die da einfach Interesse haben und was machen wollen. Das werden wir jetzt in der nächsten Zeit, in den nächsten Wochen noch ein bisschen ausarbeiten und,
bekanntgeben, als das bisher bekannt ist, ist jetzt gerade erst frische Nachricht, dass dieser Raum überhaupt zur Verfügung steht.
Ja und ansonsten auch bei schlechtem Wetter äh ist das bei der Republika sicherlich ganz nett. Ich habe die ähm.
Als ich die Republik hat schon irgendwie inzwischen eine enorme Bedeutung so erlangt, ne? Es ist echt äh.
Na klar, ich meine, was gibt's denn sonst? Die meisten anderen Veranstaltungen sind immer so merkwürdige äh Sesselpupser wichtig Tour Events, ja, wo du zwar viel Geldes Haar hast, aber ansonsten relativ wenig äh,
Butter bei Fische.
Mal so ein bisschen mein Eindruck und ich finde grad so diese Dualität mit der Republika und dem Kongress im Jahresverlauf ganz interessant, ne? Also der Kongress so im tiefen Winter, Republika, äh eher halt so äh,
wenn der wenn der Frühling sich zeigt ähm mit signifikanten Abstand, sind ja jetzt vier Monate dazwischen.
Ähm,
Markieren so markiert so die beiden Momente, wo einfach so eine gewisse Netzbewegte Szene sich auch einfach trifft. Und ist jetzt nicht nur um Business geht.
Beim Kongresse eigentlich gar nicht. Bei der Republika ist es halt so eine Mischung, aber ich finde die Mischung bisher,
fand ich sie immer erträglich, ja? Muss man jedes Mal wieder äh neu abwägen. Gibt ja Leute, die sind überhaupt schon äh abgetörnt, wenn irgendwie eine Veranstaltungsponsoren hat. Aber ist natürlich auch klar, dass die Republika nicht so wie der,
Club von so einer Community getragen wird. Also es gibt da zwar eine Community, aber das ist jetzt anders,
als im äh Club, wo die ganze Community so aus sich heraus für sich diesen Event baut. Und damit natürlich auch mit ganz anderen ähm,
Chancen äh der Finanzierung lebt, weil sie einfach vieles nicht bezahlen muss, wo eine Republica da in die Vollen gehen muss,
klar. Und äh dementsprechend muss da mehr Geld äh erzeugt werden, das will und kann man nicht alles über Tickets machen,
Also es ist ja auch jetzt keine Konferenz, weiß gar nicht, was sind die Regelpreise bei der Republika? Ist aber auch so alles so im im.
Um die hundert Euro und weniger Bereich gewesen, oder? Bin auch schon mal nach, bevor ich hier äh Quatsch erzähle. Auf jeden Fall Konferenzen dieser Art. Ja, fressen ja sonst im Businessbereich auch gerne mal vierstellige Summen.
Also, ja, drei Tage Ticket, hundertfünfzig Euro. Das ist jetzt nicht geschenkt, aber.
Es ist auch nichts.
Wer wer da war, wird da am Ende sein Geld nicht böse sein.
Nee, zumal, wenn du mal rechnest, was du für einen Aufwand hast, um um überhaupt an so einer Konferenz teilzunehmen. Ich meine, da hast du drei Tage Übernachtung und eine Anreise, also da ist einfach der, der Eintrittspreis wirklich noch das geringste Problem.
Also wer sich davon abschrecken, dass der hat andere Probleme.
Ja gut, ist trotzdem für einige natürlich eine signifikante äh signifikante Ausgabe
aber dann zum Beispiel auch dadurch, dass man da äh also auch die Republika sucht nach Helferlein, die dann da irgendwie beim Einlass helfen oder was nicht alles äh und dafür ein äh entsprechendes
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, ganz umsonst oder oder wie auch immer, äh kein, kann ich nicht genau sagen, aber auch da gibt's also Möglichkeiten,
irgendwie mit unterstützen möchte, weiß das nicht ganz genau, wie das da läuft. Ähm.
Und was ich letztes Jahr auch sehr spannend fand, sie haben ja tatsächlich einen Teil dieser Veranstaltung, nämlich diesen Außenbereich, der jetzt dieses Jahr wegen des äh Eissturmes äh nicht nutzbar sein wird,
Da konnte man auch äh letztes Jahr in dem Bereich konnte man also auch ohne Ticket, das war da waren also einfach so,
dieser Community-Bereich war dann auch äh einfach auch so zugänglich, was dann auch dazu geführt hat, dass da äh einige Leute, die vielleicht äh aus beruflichen Gründen dann sich nicht da die.
Der nicht überdachte Bereich.
Der nicht überdachte Bereich war eben auch frei und das ist, glaube ich, auch dieses Jahr wieder so.
Sich, glaube ich, da auch gar nicht anders machen.
Ah, doch, du könntest, aber egal, ne, also äh das ist schon äh ja.
Also wer jetzt voll knauserig ist, aber eh in der Gegend, der kann dann zumindest da draußen rumlungern und immer noch viele interessante Leute treffen.
Genau und äh da das war da sicherlich auch der sehr netter Bereich. So ansonsten kann man, wir müssen jetzt mal langsam hier äh zum Ende kommen, Tim. Ähm man kann auf der ähm auf der Seite dann auch einige sehr ähm,
erlesene Speaker sehen, also werden auch durchaus einige sehr interessante Personen auch aus dem, aus dem Ausland dann einge äh flogen. Ähm.
Ich denke, wir werden auch in den nächsten Wochen uns das nochmal ein bisschen genauer anschauen und euch dann gegebenenfalls selektiv noch auf ein paar Vorträge hinweisen und nicht nur auf unsere eigenen. Aber da dürft ihr natürlich auch kommen.
Genau, das war's. Bis bald.
Bis dahin. Ciao, ciao. Ich muss los.